I think why I love sports it's like I
did a whole thing at the show Once it's
the less institution I can trust like I
don't trust anything all right I don't
trust the media I don't trust the
government I don't blame you no I right
I don't blame you no I know I don't
blame you but I
but there are nepo babies everywhere
right even modeling now used to have to
really be no right it's all the children
of right are a lot of okay politics Show
Business there are no nepo babies in
sports bronny James yeah everybody wants
to see him play with his father but he
will not get on that team unless he
absolutely earns it I have total trust
that the 600 people who play in baseball
whatever it is 400 500 in in best are
the best in the world right am I right
right you're right you're right about it
if you're talking about the athletes
there's certainly nepo babies in a front
office there's neppo baby coaching staff
make no mistake about that in the World
of Sports but not when it comes to the
here's the reason why you're performing
in a public platform you don't get to
suck and the audience is going to ignore
you you're not getting away and they
want to win and they want well again
they want to win but for example one of
the rare occasions where that happens
Janna sent to D kmo for the Milwaukee
books for the Milwaukee Bucks his little
brother is on the roster and gets no
gets no playing time whatsoever that's
the closest thing you can point to to a
but that's about it you've got to be
able to play in like with bronny James
here's the interesting part about that I
think that kid can play I think he's got
potential is he there yet no but I think
he's got the potential to be there but
LeBron James went front and center from
day one and said I want to play in the
NBA with my son and because LeBron James
is still a lead averaging nearly 25 a
game at the age of 39 on his 21st season
in professional in professional
basketball he's such a money maker that
the thought of LeBron James come into
any franchise even if it's just for a
year you're thinking about the financial
winfall from all that and if LeBron
comes there and all we got to do is get
bronny James you never know who might
decide to do that but in the end if
bronnie James makes it to the NBA and he
ultimately survives in the NBA it will
be because he can play not because of
his dad so you're absolutely right the
nepple babies that you're talking about
that doesn't happen in professional
sports the public won't let you get away
with
it